why is working with color so hard
it's part art part science and if you
don't know what you're doing
mostly just frustrating hello friend
i'm greg gunn and i'm here to help you
make better color choices
in this video i'll share five tips to
keep in mind for whenever you find
yourself
struggling with a color wheel these are
fundamental concepts that
every artist and designer should know
and understand
and each one of them will help your work
look more dynamic and cohesive
that being said if you do want to learn
color theory and
go deeper about how to use it in your
own work then check out my course color
for creatives
we cover everything you'd ever want to
know about color theory
as for the rest of you here comes tip
number one
color harmonies people love to ask hey
greg
where do i even start with color it's a
good question
and my answer to them is always start
with color harmonies
color harmonies are historically proven
science-backed techniques to pair colors
together
in visually pleasing ways which sounds
way more complicated than it actually is
in fact you probably already know some
color harmony terms like
monochromatic complementary and
analogous
all they do is describe the relationship
between where these colors are
on the color wheel some apps even have
color harmony tools built right into
them
like adobe illustrator's color guide and
procreate's color harmony tool
okay let's say you love this orange but
you're not quite sure what to pair with
it
color harmonies to the rescue you can
play with different harmonies
see what you like and then adjust to
taste
in this case i'm feeling like split
complimentary is the move
so if you're not quite sure where to
start consider a color harmony
all you need to do is find one color
that you like and then let science do
the rest
tip number two neutral colors
neutral colors are like the supporting
cast for your lead colors
they can be warm cool light or dark and
they tend to recede into the background
leaving room
for your big bold color choices the most
common neutral colors
are blacks whites grays and browns and
their most notable trait is that you
can't really tell what the underlying
color
is hence the term neutral the benefit of
using neutrals is that they offer visual
relief
from your primary colors and by contrast
they make those colors
stand out that much more think of them
like negative space
but for color and you probably need more
than you think
tip number three less is more the most
common color mistake i see
is overuse and the second most common is
over saturation
the more colors you have to work with
the more difficult it becomes to get
them to work together
if they're all bold bright and vibrant
it can become a
real mess and i get it i love using all
the colors
we've got this endless supply of digital
crayons why not use the whole box
and you know what we totally should just
maybe not
all at the same time and on the same
project think about when you cook
you don't use all the spices from the
rack just the ones that you know will
make the dish taste
really good so before you go wild with
color
think about the mood you want to create
the visual flavor so to speak
because maybe all you need is some salt
pepper and smoked paprika
start with two colors and maybe two
neutrals
see how that goes you can always add
more later
tip number four contrast
okay want to know the real secret about
using color well
contrast it sounds counterintuitive but
the way your image looks in grayscale
will determine how good it looks in full
color the value of a color as in its
lightness
is almost more important than the color
itself
because without enough light and dark
contrast your image will be lost
and at that point the colors don't
really matter
low contrast is a great way to frustrate
and alienate people from your work
especially when typography is involved
not only will low contrast make
something difficult to read see or
experience
but it can render your message illegible
or even invisible to people with color
blindness
which is why having strong contrast
especially with type
is crucial to accessible design my
general rule of thumb
if it works in grayscale it'll work in
color so get in the habit of checking
your color values
the easiest way to do that convert your
work to grayscale
and if you're using photoshop set your
proof mode to grayscale and then tap
command y or control y
to toggle a black and white preview and
big ups to mark obuchi for that clever
time saving tip
tip number five aim for balance
working with color is a lot like playing
an instrument you want things to just
kind of naturally flow you don't want to
play the same chord at the same speed at
the same
volume throughout the whole song it'll
get really boring
and this is coming from a guy who loves
metal
imagine your colors are musical notes
[Music]
you want to make sure there's a nice
range of values
of hues and of saturation it's all about
the relationships between colors
you can't have light without dark
and everything else in between
not every color needs to be a star
either let one or two take the lead and
then have the rest keep rhythm
remember neutral colors
[Music]
they're the rhythm section also think
about how much of each color you're
using
the 60 30 10 rule is a great place to
start
in this case we'd use our primary sixty
percent of the time
our neutrals thirty percent and save our
accent color for the very last ten
percent
striking the right balance with colors
is tough it's like the sum of the first
four tips
you want harmonious colors room to
breathe and plenty of contrast
bonus tip now despite what you might
hear strangers on youtube tell you
there are no hard and fast rules for
using color there are best practices and
methods that work really well like color
harmonies but ultimately it's a
subjective experience
so my last tip for you is this make your
own rules it's your work you can use
whatever colors you want
however you want my two cents though
just be consistent
in how you use them that way we the
viewer
understand what the rules are and we
have a much better experience
so if you want to make your highlights
green and your shadow colors orange
go for it just make sure that all your
shadows and highlights
follow suit like i said up front
working with color can be really
frustrating which is why understanding
concepts like color harmonies and
contrast
is so important i gave you six tips in
this video but if there's
one thing i hope you take away it's the
concept of balance
striking the right balance between
contrast quantity and color usage
is what will make the biggest difference
in your work so remember
color is a lot like music each note has
its place
and the quiet moments are just as
important as the loud ones
what's your favorite color tip share it
in the comments below and let's use the
collective power of the internet
to make a color tip mega thread also if
you really want to step up your color
game
then consider taking my course we cover
color theory
how to build your own palette and work
on a real project
together you can learn more about it by
visiting thefuture.com
color and most importantly thank you for
spending some of your time with me today
see in the next one
[Music]
you